of course I had people at et reached out
me they have Star Trek questions for you
a lot of people want to know is there
potential for you to guest star on Star
Trek Picard would you revisit the role I
think that it is reasonable to assume
that those people are still a part of
cars yeah yeah yeah yeah you're doing it
although you know well you know since we
will see you all what would you want
that return to be did you you seem like
somebody who you know you have a
creative vision and you want things to
and you're connected to the the parts
that you've played in the things you've
done so what did you want it to look
like I suggested to the producers that
you know perhaps Geordi had refined Jory
in a position where he is teaching
passing that knowledge and information
on to another generation of people we'll
see you know Alex and the folks are in
charge and they're doing an amazing job
and you know when they call and whatever
is they want to do I'm pretty sure okay
so nothing filmed yet no nothing you
they can okay but it sounds like it's
been talked about talking about sounds
like maybe it deals already been signed
well thank you for for giving fans some
hope and some light because we all need
it right now so I'm sure that potential
would make people very happy
and it's I mean it sounds like that's
something you would enjoy without
question during the filming season one
the day that Jonathan and marine over
there playing the records and you know
we are family to one another we had one
of these in conversations for Maria's
birthday a couple of weeks ago we
chemistry that that people talk about
that they experienced on the show it
really is a dynamic that exists among us
and when I got married
Rick's fine it was my best man my crews
were Michael Doren Jonathan Frakes and
Patrick Stewart we are those people to
one another and anytime we get together
it's just awesome okay you got to tell
me what that zoom conference was like
serious was it was it a couple cocktails
now was that one of those things because
I find that people are I don't know how
much you guys were keeping in touch
before I find a lot of people in this
are sort of like zooming with people
they haven't talked to in a while you
know maybe you do have a little extra
time so you're suddenly like hey let me
catch up with somebody I hadn't talked
to or did you guys speak pretty
regularly in touch we you know what I
think the fact that we are all station
and and forced into this sort of sitting
still really has made us more accessible
to one another we we we just have it we
are all traveling and
you know everybody around the world is
in the same boat I think that sense of
staying put really does lend itself to
more connection also everybody keeps
talking about who do you wish you could
quarantine with what would it be like if
that group was all quarantined together
um when we are together it's like high
school for us we we revert back to the
cells that we we forged in 1987 we all
have the same joke references and and
it's just it is like like being thrust
right back into our high school days
just in terms of the energy I would
absolutely love to be quarantine with my
cast mates I can hardly think of a more
fun situation it's gonna be like putting
together a big jigsaw puzzle when you
don't even know what the picture is
supposed to be yep any other quarantine
first that you've experienced quarantine
first well you know like everybody I'm
spending a lot of time online in you
know video sessions like this stand look
it's weird in the sense that on Star
Trek we sort of modeled this kind of
technology years before in advance of
actually being available to us and kind
of did you all over because here we are
[Music]
communicating with people great
distances from if only we could beam to
each other
[Music]